right I have never had american-made
poutine I don't know what they think
poutine is people call it disco fries
here and that turns me off
I remember this looking better smells a
bit like gasoline is that today
should I be eating this very gelatinous
okay here we go here we go the cheese
curds look like they're shredded it
doesn't get awful but it's kind of got
the texture of glue is terrible
I would pay like three dollars at the
most for this Canadian I would not pay
anything for this you'd have to pay me
to use no this one's got a garnish this
one doesn't have cheese curds I don't
think the routine should have a garnish
I mean there's no discernible gravy
there's no discernible cheese curds this
is also terrible
the fries are well done which I like I
paid I paid three bucks for this I mean
that's ridiculous
poutine is like a snack food
mm just chunks of meat in here way too
meaty I feel like I'm gonna regret
learning what this watch the meat is
great fine hard to mess up still not my
favorite but you know eat a edible
my goal is eat poutine this is not it
spensive here are they important
everything from Quebec it doesn't taste
like it this is not the game you tried
America I think that's the important
part I feel bad for my American friends
that have to try this and this is what
they think poutine is this has made me a
little homesick and a little tell me sir
that was a thing that happened